new numbers released this morning by
triple-a show and historic rise than the
number of deaths from hit-and-run
crashes more than 2,000 people were
killed in hit and runs in the United
States in 2016 the last year on record
and that's an all-time high and a 60
percent increase from 2009 Kris Van
Cleave is in Washington DC with what's
behind these troubling new figures Kris
good morning
good morning every 43 seconds in the US
somebody is involved in a hit-and-run
accident
one in five pedestrian deaths are due to
hit and runs Triple A believes part of
what's driving that surge particularly
in urban areas is as cities have become
more walkable and have been encouraging
people to cycle to work they haven't
built infrastructure like this where
there is a divided area for a bike lane
that's protected from traffic that's a
picture Kampai
Cindy Cooper's father John was riding
his motorcycle when he was struck and
killed by a car that ran a stop sign and
took off in June of 2007 we've gone
through and we tried to like figure out
what had happened and how this could
have been prevented
she says the driver who killed her
father was a 17 year old using her cell
phone in 2016 nearly 2000 deadly hit and
run accidents claimed a record 2049
lives pedestrians and cyclists make up
nearly 65% of those killed by a
hit-and-run driver this dash cam caught
the most common type of hit-and-run
crash one that results in property
damage watch as the driver of this
dark-colored SUV sideswipes another
vehicle and just keeps on going
obvious potential contributing factors
might be distraction for pedestrians
cyclists and motorists alike Jake Nelson
from triple-a and also just the fact
that as more people are out there
walking and biking everyday there are
not the infrastructure countermeasures
to protect them triple-a also found
research on hit-and-run drivers is
limited because those at fault often get
away oftentimes we don't know who these
hit run drivers are we only know what we
know about the victims when the crashes
are deadly some research shows the
driver is more likely to be a young male
with a prior history of driving under
the influence and license suspension and
tends to drive an older model car
studies found drivers who leave the
scene are between two and nine times
more likely to have been intoxicated at
the time of the crash
but Cindy Cooper hopes her story can
help change this trend raising awareness
is how I feel like we can combat this
it's just going to make that hopefully
in that number to go down now every
state in the u.s. has laws against
fleeing
scene of an accident Colorado and some
cities in California have implemented an
Amber Alert style system that sends out
text and email alerts when there's been
a hit-and-run with a description of that
driver Norah alright Chris thank you so
much